let's talk uh treasury yields the world
has gone mad everyone is freaking out
we've got the uh russia ukraine conflict
we've got all kinds of chaos in various
asset classes uh and treasury yields
they just look like they're going to the
moon like they may beat elon musk to
mars what's going on here
yeah so i mean we've been talking a lot
about bonds lately uh and people have
been asking me you know why we focus
focusing so much on on treasury yields
bond markets you know if if you're more
of a bitcoin analyst and the reality is
that you know these credit markets are
really driving the performance of every
single asset class right now um so i
mean everyone knows a story right record
high inflation uh 40 near 50-year highs
producer price index just came in at 10
highest reading ever month uh year over
year um so so right something's broken
and credit markets are telling you uh
and so fixed income is selling off in a
big way and what that means is
the yields and fixed income and the
price are inverse so when fixed income
investors are selling their bonds the
yields are going up so here we have the
treasury market which is the risk-free
still the risk-free asset and the in in
the you know bond market the global bond
market and yields are soaring right
especially off of the 2020 2021 lows
so what does that mean it means higher
discount rates across the entire
economic system um so whether you're
you're valuing an equity or whether
you're trying to you know get corporate
financing uh higher discount rates
you know can give you some trouble um
and this is because of this inflationary
environment so we have this historically
over-indebted economy uh with yields
rising in a big big way and so uh you
know there's i think there we're going
to see some volatility in the coming you
know months maybe a year i tend to think
that's exactly what this is telling us
if we look at the 10-year treasury yield
the recent spike uh is obviously running
counter-cyclical if you will or counter
to the long-term trend which since the
early 80s
has just been uh down and to the right
you've got this great chart here showing
us this what's going on and why is this
so important to understand uh why this
is going up uh against the trend
yeah so i mean since 1980 81 really
we've been in the secular uh everything
everything full run but really what's
driving us is is uh the bond market
right so uh lower discount rates lower
yields means price of everything goes to
the moon um and so basically a lot of
those you know there's a few key drivers
here uh debt demographics but really uh
what we see here is kind of a bunch of
short-term debt cycles formulating a
long-term debt cycle so every every time
there's you know a boom in the economy
uh everyone kind of levers up takes on
credit uh male investment occurs and
then somewhere kind of in this eight to
ten year cycle and this is more of just
kind of an archetype debt cycle uh
there's there's somewhat of a of a crash
there's a credit crunch a liquidity
crunch and some of that bad investment
you know gets gets liquidated or there's
a recession right
but what happens after that is that the
fed this kind of keynesian economic
system they come in and they they lower
discount rates they they lower bond
yields and they kind of restimulate this
economy and so now uh you know following
oa we hit that zero lower bound on the
fed funds rate and so they did all sorts
of things they did quantitative easing
they did anything to stimulate the
economy and now following kovid which
was kind of this black swan economic
event they popped a bunch more money in
the system uh inflation's soaring but
they don't really have any tools left in
the toolbox and so now even though the
fed hasn't raised rates and you know
they'll do it probably 25 basis points
in the coming coming day here uh it
really the treasury market's taking
taking it like doing their work for them
and then the yields are selling off in a
big big way and so you know we have this
kind of 40-year trend in the in the
making here
and then you know if you'll get any
higher it's gonna it's gonna spell some
trouble for the broader economy
got it and so if we start to then break
this down by the various types of bonds
uh you've got corporate junk bonds the
vix s p 500 and looking at these there's
obviously relationships whether it's a
positive or negative correlation between
these what are you seeing here
yeah so um we have we have the high
yield bonds and then we have like we
talked about the kind of the inverse is
those yields right so you can see every
time these kind of uh the bond market
rolls over specifically you know
corporate bonds and it should be noted
that now we're in it we're in a time in
2022 um compared to say the previous
couple decades were more of the
corporate bond market than ever due to
just kind of the amount of debt they all
have on their balance sheet are in this
kind of junk rating triple b rating um
so and the vix for those that don't know
is the s p 500 uh equity volatility
index so the higher vix means uh it
needs trouble for equities um so you can
see this pretty interesting correlation
as bonds sell off and as yields soar
volatility spikes and equities get
killed um and so now you know if you're
just looking at the chart looking at
corporate bonds they're really rolling
over and you see those yields
those junk bond yields really bending
upwards um so that means higher
financing costs it means for this you
know historically over-indebted
corporates they have to roll that debt
over and it comes it's coming at a you
know much higher rate and so and the
crazy thing is you know a junk bond
right that means you're you're a poor
credit means that you could default on
your debt but yields are only six
percent we have cpi that's going to come
in here at eight percent probably with
this next cpi reading so even before
default risk this isn't this isn't like
a sovereign this isn't the united states
government so they they can't they can
nominally default so even before default
risk you know there's a negative real
yield so
yields have a long way to go uh and the
debt debt markets are still very very
mispriced um so what that's telling
everybody is that you know they're
unless the fed comes in and i think
ultimately the end game is some form of
yield curve control um there is a lot
more pain uh to come in these in these
debt markets and expect volatility
expect volatility is a great way to put
it uh you've got a chart here of the
vanguard total bond market etf and this
thing just seems to be in a free fall
what is that showing you
yeah so just kind of another one of
these uh things to watch uh bnd is the
ticker uh it just takes basically all
all bond market and just kind of
compiles it into one etf gives you
exposure and you can you get a kind of a
coupon dividend payment if you hold the
ctf
but really just looking at the chart um
especially since kova you see that kind
of rapid fall and then fed comes in
saves a day and a quick rebound but
that's this is falling off a cliff so in
terms of just like the overall market to
leveraging that we're starting to see um
and we're gonna get to bitcoin in a
second but just talking about the kind
of the global liquidity environment that
the kind of across asset classes uh
performance uh deleveraging is kind of
in the making here and so uh it'll be
really interesting to see what that pain
point is for markets for the fed for the
broader economy because it is coming um
liquidity like conditions are tightening
financial conditions are materially
tightening um and it's because of this
record-high inflation environment where
fixed income
kind of paradoxically high inflation is
not good for asset prices because these
fixed income instruments really really
sell off and and the second and third
order effects of that uh are are large
absolutely we've uh got the bitcoin uh
kind of data as we've looked at this and
you've got the futures three month
annualized rolling basis uh and this
just appears to keep going down over
time uh over the last you know call it
six to eight months or so what is that
showing you and why do you think this is
so important
yeah so i kind of have three prongs to
my market analysis especially with
bitcoin you know we the first part um
and what's driving really everything
right now is the macro backdrop um and
so we have kind of this long view this
this uh thesis that the the global fiat
currency environment uh is is so over
indebted that the endgame is um
essentially you know
uh perpetual inflation perpetual
monetary expansion that's the macro
environment and we're you know kind of
in this circular
or this uh you know little intermediate
term kind of risk off environment so
that the macro is the first prong second
prong is it's kind of the supply side
dynamics on chain we can look at all
this really cool stuff we have this
secular adoption of bitcoin the asset
itself and the third and that's really
important for price action is
derivatives right and so you can see
here during kind of the two
bull runs we saw in 2020 uh 2021
we saw this kind of derivative market
speculation really really pick up and so
this annualized rolling basis
essentially what it is
as you can sell futures contracts for
bitcoin uh and and you can short this
and you can long the spot instrument and
you can capture kind of this risk-free
neutral yield so in april you could get
like a 45 annualized return by just
selling three month futures long spot
capturing the difference this this
happens in other commodity markets as
well you see like oil will trade you
know ahead of the current spot price or
below the spot price which is called
backwardation ahead is called contango
um so really right now these contango
yields are almost nothing it's like
three percent annualized so it's trading
like in the three months future is
trading like barely one percent over the
spot price so all of this kind of
derivative speculation native to the
bitcoin to the crypto markets uh what
this is telling you is it's gone it's
basically all gone it's it's completely
unwound since november um and so you
know there's there's not really uh kind
of that that chance for a huge huge
deliberating event you know liquidity of
event in the in the legacy markets aside
that's speculation and that uh you know
kind of open interest that leads to
these really huge long liquidation
cascades um it's it's it's looking
pretty healthy in that regard hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time